Truth is, Nico gives me gay liberal energy ever since he snaked
Nick for no reason. What's crazy is I feel bad for avoiding the
guy, so I still give him a lot of advice from a distance so he
doesn't morph into a gay liberal at supersonic speeds. Everybody
here knows Trump couldn't get away with murder. No, no, no, no,
no, no. Everybody's corrupt. Trump has has like tripled his net
worth already, okay? He is the most corrupt president of all
time. Everybody's corrupt. I just want the president who could
get away with murder. That's all I
I'm opening up the Sneakers.
Sneak Zirka video. Okay. Full Sneo and Zirka friendly beef. Was
it friendly? Let's Let's see. Let's see what's going on. >> Breaking
up with you.
>> Uh yeah. What do you think? It's funny because uh you
know, Zurka was calling me uh leaf in the wind saying I blow
all over the place and
>> totally valid criticism. Totally valid
Engage with the criticism. engage with all of your changes in
ideology over time
and and argue why that's not the case. Okay, now sneak over he's
smart. He can hit back on this. He can just go, "Yeah, you too,
Zirka.
I forget. Zirka, are you like a are you MAGA this week? Are you
doing black magic this week? What the [__] are you
doing?" >> And I saw him tweet that numerology was a scam.
And I remember like that's the biggest grift of all time when
his content for a year straight was being a numerology TTS reader.
He was a palm reader for the chat for a year and then he says
it's stupid and it went back to Christianity. He spent a year
doing Cabala magic and pretending like he was a palm reader and
then he calls me a leaf in the wind. Like that was the most arc
of all time. And the fact that nobody calls it out for being
a leaf in the wind is disingenuous. I have that reputation because
I reverted to Islam three years ago.
But he was he spent a year doing palm readings for men online.
That was the most ever. And I say that out of love cuz you know
I like Zarker. We talk.
>> You have no place to ever call me. >> He says
it out of love, guys. I just say I I call you a total grifter
out of >> A grifter again after that. And now you're saying
it it's stupid. Like that was your personality for a year. You
were a crystal girl for a year and that was not only just like
a personal belief, but you made it your content and your identity.
That was more people need to call that out. But I think uh other
people get different excuses and different
are held to different standards. I think
that's absolutely true.
>> I think the difference with Zero was he was always memeing,
right? Like it was like I I I'm sorry. Sneak was very sincere
in his beliefs. Zo was like pretty goofy. Zero was like all over
the >> I feel like it's a very big difference,
>> that's just me. That's just me. Send signal. Thank you
for the gifted sub. Appreciate it. I'm I'm just resetting this
timer really quickly as well. Or sorry, the the tracker for the
>> um Yeah. No, I don't even know what that was. People
were texting me like, "Oh, she's coming to New York." Like, "I
don't even know what you're talking about. When will you start
palm readings?" Never. I will never stoop that low. I will never
stoop that low >> for old videos now. No, I I want to I
want to continue the new videos, but I don't want to put in a
bunch of effort on the second channel or the daily uploads if
I'm not monetized. It doesn't make any sense. I have all these
videos in my vault that I could upload. Why would I invest a
bunch of time into new videos when I'm not making money yet?
Bro, YouTube said that they would like that it takes 30 days
to review your channel
for monetization. I was unbanned October 15th, October 14th.
It's November 23rd and they're still reviewing it. I haven't
been rejected or I haven't been accepted yet. It's been well
over 30 days and it's super annoying. And I saw, shout out to
Accumulated Thoughts, Brain Eo. The Clippers are getting monetized.
>> No, I'm not. I'm The main channel is not monetized.
I am not. >> This accumulated thoughts channel is making
him a lot of money. It's pretty >> Enough time has passed.
We want to see people create.
>> I think this is this is like somewhat smart. Just stream,
right? Streaming like makes you a lot of money. So, just stream
and then let them upload >> on YouTube.
>> And they're getting email them. Okay. Don't tell me
what to do, Nas. Like, do you think that I don't? Of course,
I'm in contact with them. They just keep telling me wait. They're
saying just wait. They're They're saying it's in review.
So, apparently they're watching everything. It's uh Yeah. And
I'm happy for the Clippers, but it's like they got me in timeout.
They're punishing. Wait to see if I'm on good behavior. But it's
just it's super frustrating from my perspective. It's like why
would I
do all this work for videos that I'm not making money from? No.
Accumulated thoughts is monetized. He just told me. He just told
me. Did they just text me just now? Okay. No, it's this girl.
Actually, I'm capping like it was the YouTube manager. It was
a girl texting me, but I'm telling her I'm streaming now. I said,
"Hey, hey, hey, I'm busy talking to >> He definitely didn't."
He's like, he >> is not Neo.
>> Sne is like such a soft boy at heart.
>> Brian and my take on that. I'm busy talking to the comm
right now. That's what I said. Didn't you see say in the video
you're not doing YouTube for art on money? No, obviously. Yeah,
that's like the reason I'm doing it, but also you shouldn't do.
>> He He texted her back. He was like, "Hey, if you if
you want to like hang out right now, I'll end the stream right
now." That's what he texted about free. Cuz if I was just doing
this strictly for money, then I would Oh my god, I hate having
to explain this every day. But if I was doing this strictly for
money, I would just take the gaming deal and just be [__]
done with this. I wouldn't have to be grinding the way I'm grinding.
Duh. I would be like Andrew hat and take the gambling deal after
years of complaining about degeneracy. Degeneracy. Degeneracy
is ruining the West. I would never stream on kick because there's
gambling on kick and then he takes the gambling deal, you know?
Super dis >> Wait, who did Andrew who did Andrew take a
gambling deal from? Dude, everybody takes the gambling deal.
I swear to God, I'm going to sit here. I'm going to be like homeless
in five years, okay? I'm going be on the street being like, "You
know what? At least I still have my integrity. At least I still
have I I never took the gambling money. I never took the state
contract. Okay, at least I still have my integrity." Disappointing.
I obviously didn't want to, you know, you don't want to like
talk about that too much, but it's just like like >> Merk
got a gambling deal today. Crazy. >> I know. Like being
a content creator, you got to act like you didn't see all that
stuff for years. Like degeneracy. The West is all degenerate.
Every time I look online,
>> I the thing about the gambling deal is like I don't
even have I like gambling. It's like it's self-interest and then
I do think basically you're feeding into a s like a a system
that
like is just churning through people. It just like chews people
up and and ruins lives. You're and you're building directly into
it. I man I can't. It's like hey what do you think about strictly
FIGHTING SNEAK I OWE THIS >> Go to duel.com/tate. You know
what?
Yeah. If I was doing this strictly for money I just like that's
what I would do. Bro, those [snorts] hands are cool. It's cold,
bro. I was outside grinding. If I was doing this just for money,
you think I'd be [__] freezing cold in a train station
interviewing people about socialism. No, >> he he gets
to the Zirka tweets eventually, trust me. >> No, I wouldn't.
Anyway, I want you to do the right thing and stuff. Don't clip
that and make it like make sure that if you clip that, include
the part where I'm saying something positive. He says positive
things, blah blah. I want him to do good things. Zer's calling
you a gay liberal on Twitter. Yeah, Zurka only talks [__]
because he's trying to get clout. He doesn't stream anymore.
He's Canadian. It's like go back to Canada. Also, most white
people don't even consider Albanians white. They think Albanian
are low IQ and Slavic monkeys. Like, he's trying to become part
of that group. I mean, look, bro.
Most Canadians don't consider Wait, what? Maybe Americans. Dude,
Canadians,
trust me, in Canada, Zerka absolutely qualifies as white compared
to most of the immigrants coming. I I we don't have a lot of
pickiness on who we consider white here. Okay, that's just not
true. >> I love this stuff. >> What's the brokerest
you ever been? >> Um I've been in extreme amounts of debt,
but I was probably broker when I before debt, like mentality
wise when I was, you know, working. No, probably when I was um
probably when I was um let's see this tweet. [snorts] Paying
off the debt. Pay working for Uber Eats. Let's see. Dude, I didn't.
No, you didn't cancel on me. You >> Okay, let's check it
out. Uh, Sneo is mad at me because I cancelceled at him five
times in a row this year without telling him why. The truth is
Nico gives me gay liberal energy ever since he snaked Nick for
no reason. What's crazy is I feel bad for avoiding the guy. So,
I still give him a lot of advice from a distance, so he doesn't
morph into a gay liberal at supersonic speeds. >> I'm not
mad at Zerg, bro. Like, okay. All right, bro. This goof.
He says, uh, see mad because I canceled once five times a row
this year without telling him why. You just tweeted trying to
like farm cloud saying you were coming to New York and I didn't
ask you to come. Tradition gives me gay liberal energy ever since
he snick for no reason. It was crazy. I feel bad for avoiding
the guy. So I still give him a lot of advice from a distance
so he doesn't morph into a gay liberal at super you don't give
any advice like the advice. Why would people take advice from
somebody that stopped doing content? Why? Like what advice could
I take from somebody that that quit because he doesn't want to
look at the chat anymore? Why would I take it? What advice? What
advice to not be a leaf in the wind? Dude, you were >> Wait,
he didn't stop. I thought he stopped cuz he got banned for for
literally like making out with a 16-year-old on a stream.
Isn't that I thought that was the reason he stopped. What are
we talking about? He didn't want to look at the chat anymore.
The fuckologist for a year and then you quit. You were you say
that I'm a leaf in the wind and then you started doing Kabala
magic for TTS donations. If I needed advice for you on money,
then I would do that and get $5 TTS to tell somebody that they're
a eight master builder. What are you talking about?
What are you talking about?
It's just No, I don't give a I never invited you to come here.
What are you talking about? You lied about that on your Twitter.
Second off, like what?
You he tweets about me non-stop and then
>> Oh man, Sneo's like rat. Why does Sneo gets so rattled
by somebody? It's just Zirka talking. I I get he could respond,
but uh he gets he feels like he gets so rattled by Zirka. I don't
know why. Couldn't he go to party or something?
It's It's bizarre to me that that Sneo gets this rattled.
Like he he has to defend himself. Why? Why bother? >> Second,
you lied about that on your Twitter. Second off, like >> you
you constantly tweet about me. Does he really? Is it Let me If
I go to Zurka's Twitter. Hold on. Zirka Twitter.
Zurka official. Zirka official.
If I just go to Zurka's Twitter, is he going to be tweeting about
Sneo a bunch? Maybe he is. Maybe I'm wrong.
Do not go unconscious.
Not Not a Sneo tweet. Not a Sneo tweet. Well, maybe for Zerka.
Now that I've been proven innocent, like if I should be unbanned
on kick.
Uh, I don't believe that's happened.
Zero still posting his jokes. Oh, this is about Sneo, though.
Hold on. >> I love being Muslim. [laughter] I love being
Muslim. Every man should not do
>> Oh boy. That's a I see why he's Zirka now. I see why
he's getting why he's getting like rolled by Zirka. All right,
dude. You guys get it, right? Uh, heal Mike off. Sneo in the
corner on the [__] chair. I love being Muslim. I
love being >> I love being Muslim. [laughter] I love being
Muslim. Every man should go through this. Every man should go
through that. >> Leave Sneak alone.
>> That's brutal. When you were friends. Okay, that's a
thing to do to your buddy. What the hell?
>> Thoughts on Sneo? Oh, this is Dude, Zurka literally
only has like like
Zurka has 40 hours of content in him a year. Maybe even maybe
more like 80 hours of content every two years and they are really
good but then he just can't do it >> Sne
total car. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. >> No, no, no, [laughter]
no. Hey, HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT? I I'm not going to lie. I I I
Is Zurko not banned on YouTube? I don't think so. He could totally
stream a bunch of places.
All he tweets about me non-stop and then
>> Yeah, actually. Okay, now that I look at it, he is kind
of tweeting about him a lot. Sneaker remonetized. Wait, Sne was
remonetized today. Yesterday. Okay,
38.1K tuned into his space. What the
5 >> right? We have something in common.
Nico is like, "Bro, I've got no political opinions in common
with you. You're just pushing
through." >> Oh, Zerk is actually talking. Oh, >> wait.
Okay. You know, it's just Okay.
>> If anybody could sit through that Twitter space, there's
probably content there. I feel like uh I would not sit there.
I'd probably go grab like a transcript or something. >> He
says what number was it? I never invited him. He just tweeted
saying he was going to come here. [laughter] What are you talking
about? How much you going to charge? >> Actually, debate,
bro. Dude, unironically, Sneo lasted longer with an MMA like
a a UFC champion in the ring who's really try who's like actually
kind of going after him than Zerka did against HS Tick-talkie.
Oh, also is HS TikTock going to prison? >> I saw that headline
two weeks ago or something and then I never looked into it and
that just I remembered Zirka getting his ass kicked by HS TikTalkie
and I'm like wait did he go to prison? I think that your TTS
I don't know like how much until you know a lot of these people
um I don't know if you've noticed this but a lot of people fear
>> have you noticed how a lot of people are scared of Nick
Wentz as influence so they will like Nick and I are friends like
we but people will never say anything negative or they will end
up having to platform him just because of the pressure from his
fans. His fans will will berate them so much that even though
like deep down they resent him they'll bring him on just so that
their fans don't or they'll pretend to like him just so that
they don't get attacked. I have seen so many people that have
once completely disavowed him end up embracing him just because
they don't really have a choice. >> Um, yeah, that's true.
Yeah, I think I think that's easily true. That's obviously true.
Um, some of them I would say there's differences. So, some people
did that precisely.
I don't know. It's uh I think it's possible Tucker did that.
I think uh I think
I think it's more often chasing than intimidation. Maybe. I'm
trying to think of like what causes that. I think people have
a hard time understanding how algorithms work and so they see
like groper comments at the top of stuff and they're like oh
this is what everybody wants. It's hard to come it's hard to
overcome that. I think
>> and you know I don't think it's >> Although to
be fair if you pick the gropers off you will get like downvoted
to everything. You will get like totally you will get like overrun
by the cult. It's unlucky. So >> is like Zurker will talk
all this about me even though he'll say Zurker will say I made
his career which I did and he's constantly admitted that but
he will constantly constantly he's like oh I joke about you because
I care about you my friend. He will never make a joke at Nick
Fentes cuz he doesn't want to get attacked. He really he quit
his career to become like a groer Twitter account. I want better
for him. I want to be able to make content. He shouldn't just
be a clipper for Nick. >> Wait, he clips for Nick? Seems
like he's clipping some anti- Sneako stuff. Dude, he is Hold
on. After Siko said he was obsessed with me, he how he Oh, I
thought Sneo was getting rattled. No, Zurka is actually obsessed
with Sneo.
>> Favorite albums.
>> I I think Zurka made his own.
>> People People will say Zirka just says this to people.
Zirka is
>> People think Zurka is just insane. Zirka is incredibly
charismatic, incredibly good at manipulating people. Even when
he is overtly manipulative, he's successful. Okay. He says that
to people, so they'll keep having him on, so they'll keep hanging
out with him, so they'll keep doing stuff with him. You guys
are
No, that was not Zurich's big f first big appearance. Zurich's
been on a bunch of big things. Um Zirka had his whole stream,
everything that he did with uh like, wasn't he on the Raj the
Raj panels? Like Zurka built his own [__] He just
he just isn't consistent, so he goes on other people's streams,
but he was like independently funny, independently building his
own thing. If he had any discipline to him, he would be huge.
Oh, also ABBA should pay him for that bet in my opinion. >> I
listen to that is one of my favorite albums. I listen to that
all the time and I I love
so great. It's honestly is like top five EA albums for me. >> Why
why
tough? That's tough. That's a tough one. >> Like is that
really going to be your whole thing now? First off, you're Albanian
and Canadian. You're not American. Didn't you have visa problems
here? You remember when you had to leave Miami? So you're not
like And you say that I'm not American first. I spoke at Fuentes
rally, too, and endorsed him for president back in 2023. Second,
you're not American and you're an Albanian. White supremacists
think that you're a black person. It's like, bro, Clav is doing
well. It's It's cool to see.
Hey, >> I feel like Zurka told this story about how Albanians
are black so he can say the without getting in trouble. And now
other people are like, "You're Albanian. You're basically black."
They're like, he like made the scop and then they're trying to
use it against him. And he's like, "Dude, I made that fake thing
up. I totally made that up." >> See, Cloud doing his thing.
I'm not just going to make the whole stream about Circa, though.
Holy [__] What else is going on? >> He actually
gets rattled though, even though Zirka is going after him or
whatever. He does get rattled. I'm not going to make the whole
stream about Zirka. Turns out there's 10 minutes left of the
clip about Zirka. >> Zerka's texting me now. What do you
want? Interrupting my stream. [laughter]
>> No way. Slab monkey is a thing. Yes. Not looking down
on slabs is a thing. Calling them like uh black is not a thing.
Zerka punching Haz. I remember >> But I'm going to crack
them for real. I'm going to crack them right now.
Oh, sorry.
I'm a crack though, >> dude. Hey, he said he was going
to crack him. He said he was going to crack him, dude. Damn,
dude. That's kind of With new online lingo, it's kind of taking
on a whole new meaning. >> You are a weirdo for that. For
what?
I'm a weirdo for what? What did I say? Dude, like Zurka's Okay,
you want you want to talk about it? >> Zirka pretending.
Dude, Zirka is so manipulative. It's crazy. It's so funny to
watch him. Yeah, I really enjoy Zirka content. Zirka Sneo content
was actually a bit of a golden age for Rumble early on. Unironically,
that if they were doing that same show on Rumble right now with
the same energy, they would be raking money in 100%.
That show was so good that those like 5 to 10 weeks they used
to stream together and then Zurka was like living in his apartment
was a total monster and his apartment was just a tornado. Would
come through and do anything he wanted in there and Siko would
just like totally let him do whatever he wanted. Bro, it was
nuts.
That would be that would be great content now. It was always
good. Always good. [__] They need to they need to
bring it back. Sneo. Rebuild the bridge. Rebuild the bridge now.
>> Your call has been forwarded to voice. >> You
take things too personal when someone does not want to be on
your channel. Dude. >> Dude. Zirka. Just to be clear what
Zurka said, oh you're weird for that. Zirka says you're weird
for that. He calls Nico repeatedly on Twitter and then Zirka
messages him you're weird for that for saying you're Albanian
and Canadian. That's what he said. You're Albanian and Canadian.
Zurka's like, "You're weird for that one, bro." >> Zurka,
I don't want you to be on my channel. I don't need you for content.
First off, I made you. Second off, I >> You did not. You
did not. >> I never invited you to come to NEW YORK. YOU
INVITED YOURSELF and then didn't come. I didn't even You just
tweeted you were coming here. I don't need you for content, dude.
I'm not taking it
>> dude. I should I should hit Obser to come on the stream.
Okay. Oh, I might get banned from kick, though. that. Trust me,
I'm well aware of how good Zirka is. Okay, Zirka is incredibly
talented for like the four weeks he's soberish.
All right, he's just like on one eightball a night. He'll be
content. He'll be crazy.
Like he says, "Take it personal." Like he hasn't been tweeting
calling me a gay liberal and replying to all my stream clips
non-stop [laughter] for years. And then when I respond after
he calls me a leaf in the wind for years because he was a leaf
in the wind doing Cabala magic numerology,
now now he's victimizing himself.
What did you want me to do? Like, what did you want me to say?
Just be like, "Yeah, YOU'RE RIGHT, ZIRKA. AMERICA FIRST. You
Albanian Canadian." No, actually, I'm American and I'm the one
who's speaking up for this movement that you claim to be better
at me that than them. He's rage baiting you, dude. No, he's not
rage baiting. He's just Okay, let's see. [snorts] Then why does
he then Why don't you call and talk about it, [laughter]
>> dude? Unfortunately,
Zer's like, "Hey, Sinko, you're a leaf in the wind." Sneo proceeds
to do a 20-minute stream clip. Basically proving that 100% within
the first 30 seconds of Zirka texting him. Guys, this whole stream
is not going to be about Zirka. Puts down his phone. Phone vibrates,
picks it up. Zirka's texting me. Hold on. Let me talk about Zirka.
>> Well, all right. >> And now Zirka isn't picking
up the phone. So, how does this look? >> Bro, you are trying
to hang with Zirka says, "Bro, you're trying to hang with red
pill people, but red pill people don't want to hang with you."
Zirka, you can't hang with anybody because you're banned on kick
because like you you made jokes for so long. I told you not to
do that, bro. Like, bro, like, it's What do you mean red pill
people don't want to hang with? What are you talking about?
What? Red pill people don't want to hang with me? What are you?
[laughter] What is he talking about? All right. You know what?
What is So, what do people think Red Pill is being a white supremacist?
What is that, bro? Zurka, you hang out with Jack Doory. Is that
who you're talking about? >> Wait, Zurko doesn't hang out
with Jack Dhy anymore, right? Didn't Zurko like slap Jack Dohy?
No, those who the only content you in a year half is with Jack,
>> bro. Fuzzy. Oh my god, there's some great content creators
who have left us. >> And you're saying, "Oh, Red Pull people
don't want to hang out with you." I get collabs as the canceled
guy with any side like he bragging about his IQ all the time.
Dude, what content have you made besides Jack Dohy? You haven't
done a street. This is no hate on Jack Dhy. He's doing his thing.
But that guy is not Red Pill. What are you talking >> I
told Zirka not to make jokes. Hold on. >> On the left and
I think Zurka likes the girl on the right. On the left. >> What
up, girls? I forgot about this. >> How old are you? >> What
the [__] >> Oh, I got that white smiling. Let's
go. >> How old are you guys?
>> Underage. Well, you just
>> like how how how underage though? Like >> Okay.
Not the not the greatest clip, but in essence, the these streams
were great. Okay. The monkey the monkey streams with Zirk and
Sneo. Fantastic. >> Your birthday's next week type [__]
We can't go to Starbucks. Why? >> And I will be turning
15 in A MONTH.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, SO HARD TO FIND. >> WE GOT
HIM.
>> Incredibly loud. Holy. My ears are gone.
>> Rolo Tomasi. [laughter] You want to get a vasectomy
with Rolo Tamasi and be a rational male? What? I agree with Zer
who's always been a weird liberal band kid. Yo, somebody tell
Zer does somebody tell my son and it just stop talking like I
made your career. I made your career and all you do is nitpick
and don't stream. It's like, uh, you're welcome or shut up. Either
way, what are you talking about? Never invited you. I to think
that I need you for anything. I didn't I didn't I'm not mad at
you cuz you canceled. I'm just calling you a grifter because
you did numerology for a year. Now you [__] on it
because you were an astrology girl. What are you talking about?
You did TTS donations for $5 and then you pretend to give people
advice and me about money. It's stupid. I I like when people
give me unsolicited advice, it's like, what are you talking about?
your career was doing TTS palm reads and then you call me a leaf
and say I'm a liberal [laughter] like dude go like because I
don't to put America first you're
bro I I think underestimates like how weird this looks just him
arguing with text zirka won't even call like he's he's put himself
below Zirka already I understand you can argue with people in
text for a little bit but at some point you got to go okay get
on voice you can't just argue with your phone texting
Right. You're way more committed than he is. It puts you in a
certain position, man. Think about it. >> I'm out of egotistical.
I made his career. I made you. You're welcome.
Where's my 20%. No. No. I'm a good guy. I won't do that. You're
welcome. Every day you should be thanking. Thank you for reviving
my dead career and making me Thank you for making me trendy with
the red pill. Okay. Okay. He's just tweeting nonstop. He's tweeted
uh how many times about me? All right, dude. Like, I ain't reading
all this. Is he either go live or don't? Does he go abandon [laughter]
the
Dude, Cir is so crazy sometimes, dude. Look how much he's That's
crazy. That's really funny. He starts live tweeting about Sneo.
Uh, very funny,
man. The contrast between this and Sneo calling out Matt Walsh
is crazy. Like 90 minus 97% masculine. Yeah, I don't know,
dude. It's I think I think Zurka must know stuff. He must have
gotten like personal with Zirka and told told Zirka things about
himself that he doesn't want leaked. So, I feel like he's always
That's the only thing that makes sense to me. He's just always
like a little bit nicer to Zirka. He's like way too kind to Zerko
and Zirko's a total like totally him. I feel like Zurka must
know some [__] about him that like I don't know.
Maybe Sneo [__] like a 17-year-old or something in
Miami and Zirka knows about it.
Don't say that. Don't say that, Zirka. Just don't make that up.
If that's If that's true, you can say, but if it's not true,
don't make it up just cuz I said it. Okay. I feel like that's
the kind of thing Zirka does. >> Okay. He's just tweeting
on He's tweeted
how many times about me. All right, dude. Like I ain't reading
all It's either go live or don't go abandoned the red pill cuz
it was too spicy. Dude, I left that two years ago when Roamasi
said I get a vasectomy. I joined Islam because it was trending.
Bro, you joined numerology cuz you're a idiot who believes in
Cabala magic, dumbass. Or because you were just trying to scam
your fans. I joined Islam because it was trending. You joined
numerology to scam your fans away from Christ. you. So either
you're just really and fell for Cabala magic or you had no content
and you needed some money so you willingly scammed your fans
away from Christ to go and make them believe in 22.
So it's either you're extremely demonic or extremely stop talking
about me being a grifter. The are you talking about? All right.
A win with no. It's like now now it's just I only I only talked
about this. excited. I know his feelings are hurt and maybe he'll
get bullied to come back out of his uh streaming break, [snorts]
but um
I only point this out to just call it the double standard that
everybody let him get away with that numerology for so long,
bro. Uh and also [laughter] his comments are off. His comments
are off, which is just like, yeah, dude. Okay, he said, uh I
will [__] Nico's wife in front of him and he will
have a seat in his favorite sofa. Dude, don't get mad at me because
you ruined your career making yourself a >> He's upset
because he can't stream anymore and there's no really like content
for him besides >> leeching. Look, your only account, your
only Twitter, your only page left is Twitter and you're too embarrassed
to put in your replies because people call you a
>> or they bring up the fight you did >> and you
don't like to hear that, dude. It's like I don't You're mad at
me. It's either self-reflect and realize why your career was
ruined and you like to blame. >> How old is Sneo's wife?
She's of age. Um if she exists, I is he married? I think I think
Zurg is talking about a hypothetical wife or maybe Zo's married.
I have no [__] idea. >> I've been following.
>> But you need some self analysis before you think that
you're this like wiz this wizard that can give everybody advice.
I told you to stop calling yourself a and you made it your personality.
Then people started to cancel you for was it incorrect? Yeah.
I don't know the details. Hopefully it was all right. >> You
got to I Dude, how does he he's got to understand, right, how
much power he's giving Zerk over him. Like he is giving Zerka
all of the power in this situation for no reason.
>> Like just ignore him. Literally just don't respond.
Literally just say, "I don't care about Zerka's opinions. [__]
>> It's It's difficult to do, but just go hey off. I'm
not I don't want to hear it. I don't care. >> It was probably
>> you. You would literally say, "Grifter, don't care."
And move on. But >> if that's Sorry, if that's what you
actually want, if you want Circuit to come back, just say so,
dude. Stop giving him all the power and then pretending you don't
want him back. [__] help. You don't get mad at me.
I put you on in the first place. I made your career for then
you to ruin it by calling yourself a
So now when you call me a grifter non-stop and you text me during
my stream instead of going live,
shut the up.
Just shut up or be grateful. I made you. You're welcome.
You see why? And and then people wonder why I left the red pill.
It's because of people like it's because of this.
Zirkus is not relevant anymore. Whose fault is that? He's not
streaming this. His only content is tweeting about other people.
Has become being a groper clipper and just sucking off Nick Fentes
for Twitter likes. That's his career now. And you're mad at me?
I made you.
I left the red pill because Yeah, the truth is important and
stuff. It's not like I left the ideology. Oh yeah, don't get
abused by a feminist woman. Yes, great, great points. What? I'm
not I'm not red pill because I'm a white supremacist. No, it's
I left the red pill because of leeches like this. You make somebody's
career like Zirka. I made a lot of these red pill careers and
what do they do as gratitude? Do they say thank you?
>> Sne's I think here's the problem with Sneo. Okay, I
actually think at this point he's like a little too he feels
a little too bad to fully lean into lying. Like he he can't quite
do it. He can almost do it. He just can't quite like there was
something in him. He could lie before and he was fine and then
somehow as he went through in this religious journey something
changed and he feels like weird lying. He's not just he he just
calls her.
Why do you why do you say you called yourself come
come Grifter and be done with him, right? And Sneo has to learn
or Sneo has to know that that's how you actually deal with the
situation and he is not dealing with it at all. He's just like
trying to be honest with him. I also I made these red pill guys
careers. Bro, what? Andrew Tate was doing fine without you. What
are you talking about? Myin Gains is doing fine without you.
What are you talking about? Whose career did you make? or do
they start tweeting about you for clout? Zerk is following the
playbook that so many of these other red pill people have followed.
I bring them up. I I make their career. Then they fall off
and it's their own fault and they start coming at you and claiming
it's jokes. It's happened how many times?
>> Stop taking subliminals. No, this is not a subliminal.
This is direct. I made Zirka's career and now he tweets about
me after he ruined it. You're mad at me. Be mad at yourself.
>> What the [__] am I looking at, bro? Bro.
Dude, dude, what? He pulls up. >> I just to call me and
like have a conversation with me and he's tweeting in love speech
crypto saying he like that a What the am I looking at, bro? Why
are you in my Why are you in the love speech group chat arguing
with people?
What the is he doing? Give me funnier tweets. >> Give me
funny. He's just openly saying, "Give me tweets." Dude, this
guy's so I'm sorry. Durka is like funny and how shameless he
is. It's super funny to me.
He's literally sitting here in a derm chat that Siko's in. Refusing
to get on the stream and just tweeting and Siko's just biting
all of it for some reason.
>> What is he? Wait, hold on. Did you see the comment?
Hold on. [laughter] That's why you shouldn't be in the group
chat like that. But hold on. It was safe for work
at [clears throat] circa official. Is she
okay? We're not This is on YouTube. It's probably going to be
fine. >> Like, bro, what are you doing, bro? He's in love
speech crypto saying, "Oh, what are you doing, bro?
Aren't those old logs? Look like old logs to me. That Abigail
Shapiro was not Abigail Shapiro would never dress like that.
Like a total harlot. Never. Never.
Never.
Sne's reaction to the Akash Singh situation. Oh man. Nah. Nah.
Nah. Nah. Pop this shoe on head video open. It's a It's got Zoron
and Fuentes in the
>> It's got Zoron and Fuentes in the thumbnail. The Democrats
have struck back. In the New Jersey governor's race, the Democrat
won. In the Virginia governor's race, the Democrat won. And in
the New York City race, Democratic Socialist Oran Madani defeated
Andrew Cuomo to become the next mayor of America's largest city.
But the question on everyone's mind is, was it just a fluke?
Just easy wins in blue cities and states, or is there something
more to this? Is this a sign of things to come? Is the Democratic
Party finally turning their losing streak around? Are they actually
listening to the people now? Did they finally learn their lesson?
No. Thanks for watching.
My last three videos about >> No way, dude. Whenever I
watch Shu, I just think this is the one time Hutch is like justified
cuz Shu and Head for the longest time is like, I'm not a right-winger.
I'm not a right-winger. I'm not a right-winger. [laughter]
It's like she is she is like the thing Hutch has his little flowchart
for. >> Electoral politics were warning the Democratic
party that young men were moving right because the partying sucks
and was becoming the young men eat and die movement. Spanking
the Democratic Party for losing because they elected one of the
most unlikable, shittiest candidates while offering absolutely
nothing to voters. and defending the voters from the wrath of
a bunch of liberal streamer manchildren calling the voters stupid
and evil for daring not to vote for Hillary Clinton and Brownface.
But the thesis for all three of those videos was basically the
same as the right and >> I'll say I'll say it again, okay?
Just in case anyone needs to hear it loud and clear. Everyone
was wrong on Hillary Clinton. We should have voted for Hillary
Clinton. Okay,
just listen. that the future where we don't crash the world economy,
where we don't, you know, we don't fully allow Silicon Valley
to dictate what happens with the world, where where we get microchipped.
Yes, we do eat the bugs, okay? But everything else is normal.
I'm I'm down for that future. Okay, give me the other fork in
the road at this point. I I listen. Yes, Killery. Yes, give me
Killery. Okay, at least Hillary could hide her corruption.
Be honest.
Nobody here thinks Trump could get away with murder.
No, nobody here thinks Hillary couldn't get away with murder.
Everybody here knows Trump couldn't get away with murder. No,
no, no, no, no, no. Everybody's corrupt. Trump has has like tripled
his net worth already. Okay? He is the most corrupt president
of all time. Everybody's corrupt. I just want the president who
could get away with murder. That's all I want. Can we have the
leader of the free world that could get away that could plan
a murder and get away with it that is not incompetent that could
execute something like that
>> and just cold coldblooded put somebody down. I'm good
with it. Okay, cuz right now we have an emotional manchild who
can't execute on anything. Is a total.
So give me for the love of God. Give me >> Braces working
class populism. The Democratic party and the left will
>> At least Trump doesn't interns in the White House.
Uh, I'm not asking for for Bill, although Bill would also be
a massive step up, okay? I also believe Bill could get away with
murder. And Bill could get away with murder by like honey [__]
anybody who saw it. Okay, that's Bill's strategy. Hillary's different
to fade into irrelevancy. But as I also predicted in those last
videos, there might be an eventual
>> Oh. Uh, you need to deep dive the Sam Pepper India eye
thing. Those exposed videos seem to be doctorred. Well, that's
the thing, Scrotum, is I thought I I it's very funny that you
say that. Well, hold on before we get into the shoe thing. I
never care about shoe that much. I will cover the the sand pepper
stuff. Now, the exposed videos, I have no way of validating anything
there. They showed like as validation documents from the government
from like a hospital like how the eye was deformed. And I'm like,
bro, I can't read Hindi or whatever the language that is. I I
don't know the language. How do I How am I supposed to know this
isn't somebody just blackmailing Sam Pepper for money? I got
no idea. So, I don't know. We might have to We'll look into it.
Bro, you're you're Canadian. You haven't picked up Hindi yet.
>> Videos was basically the same. As the right embraces
working-class populism, the Democratic Party and the left will
continue to fade into irrelevancy. But, as I also predicted in
those last videos, there might be an eventual pendulum swing.
And it might be happening much sooner than I predicted. Like,
how did we go from Republicans winning the popular vote in part
thanks to a lot of the young people voting to a bunch of data
showing those same young people dropping their support for the
GOP already? But the interesting thing is those young people
don't seem to be moving to the Democratic party either. Where
are they going? And do the Democrats have a plan to scoop these
people up? Yes, they do. And they called it, I'm not kidding,
deciding to win. Deciding to win as if the whole time they have
just been simply deciding to lose. It was a choice, guys. They
changed their mind and they want to win. Now, in this video,
I will talk about why I think Zor and Mani won. We will go through
the Democrat party's plan to decide to win. We will briefly talk
about the rise of the political commentator Nick Fuentes, the
MAGA civil war, and what I like to call the inevitable rise of
shuselism. If that sounds interesting, stick around. If it doesn't,
you can leave. It's not like a >> It doesn't really >> miss
you or anything. >> We'll check it out. >> Baka,
I know a lot of you are not very interested in politics. You
come here for the fun Reddit slop, the men verse women content.
Yeah, yeah, I know. But unfortunately, politics kind of seeps
into your lives whether you want it to or not. So, you might
as well be entertained when you hear about it and have some fun
with it when you can. And I just so happen to have the perfect
app for that. So, before we get into this political deep dive,
let's quickly give a shout out to today's sponsor, one of my
favorite sponsors to work with, Ground News. Ground News is a
website and an app that gives readers a transparent and easy
way to read news from all across the political spectrum, from
left, right, and center. Every story comes with a quick visual
breakdown of political bias that helps you understand the full
story. And >> no,
no,
>> you go to Kyle the Democratic party for all my career.
Don't say too harshly. >> Frankly, I don't care. Some say
I'm not harsh enough on the Republicans. First of all, true.
But let's be honest, that's not why you come here. You go to
Kyle Kolinsky for that. >> Wait, hold on. I Dude, wait.
What? I don't mean this in like in any way except literally.
But I was she a part of that? I don't mean this in any way but
literally. I'm not asking for anything. I'm just saying I I had
no
>> Just like you go to Destiny to see opinions you can
hear on CNN or to Hassan for dog training tips. You come here
to hear golly G Willick on leftwing and the Democrats have gone
crazy. That's the [__] you're here for. But are the
Democrats actually getting their together? Or did they simply
get lucky in a few blue areas? One of those blue areas being
my city, New York, where Democratic Socialist candidate Zoro
Manani won the election.
>> Well, they obviously went to populism in New York. become
the new mayor. And a lot of people are like really confused about
how this happened. And if you're one of those people, you really
need to keep watching. If you don't understand why Mandani won,
I'm sorry to say, but you're kind of like the liberals in 2016
who didn't understand why Trump won. It's actually extremely
understandable why Zora Namani won. And it's not just cuz New
York is full of commies or whatever. He's objectively the best
Democratic candidate that they've had in a very, very long time.
Like I know the bar is in hell there, but he's young, he's energetic,
he's charismatic, and people are really tired of the White House
doubling as a retirement home. And of course, I like many of
his economic policies. is I like the universal childare thing,
the transportation, flipping off the Christopher Columbus statue.
That's the [__] I don't like. That's our guy. He
was a brave Italian explorer who discovered America. And in this
house, Christopher Columbus is a hero. End of story. I've said
this many times, but I don't think the good leftwing policies
can even exist alongside the bad leftwing policies. Like, I don't
know how you can have free transportation but also be soft on
crime. Like, I don't know. Like, in what
Those seem totally orthogonal to me. Those seem like unrelated.
Why? Why would those be related at all? [__] Is she
talking about >> world does that work out? You can't have
nice, clean, free transportation if a bunch of drug addicts and
violent felons are going around stabbing people and setting them
on fire. You can't have nice things.
I think Oh man, there's like a level of soft on crime that doesn't
make sense in terms of like it's not I don't even know if it's
progressive. Wait, are you serious? How do you not get that?
How do I not get Why would free buses have anything to do with
being soft on crime? Okay, I get so you're saying I maybe this
is what you're saying. Well, if you're soft on crime, people
are scared to go outside. But like nobody's arguing for that
level of soft on crime. I don't know who thinks that that people
are behind or or hopeful that when they let somebody go who has
not been convicted of multiple felonies, who has been like arrested,
you know, 10 times, 15 times, 20 times even, but has been let
go each time. when they when they don't charge that person because
they feel like they can't. There's not a single person, not a
single judge, not a single cop, nobody who's like, "Oh, I really
hope that guy goes to a gas station, gets a bucket full of gasoline,
dumps it on a woman, and sets her on fire."
That's not the goal of the policy, right? That's just not the
goal of the policy. You're a complete [__] if you
think that's the goal of the policy. You You are believing You
are like Tim Pier if you think that's the goal of the policy.
That's like That is literally like the Tim Pool motto is these
people are evil. This isn't like an accident. It's just mis it's
like not misguided. It's evil,
right? It is misguided. And people will realize these policies
are misguided and they will update them. They'll change them.
Nobody sticks with policies like this for very long. Okay? But
like that's that's why you can't say that, oh, soft on crime.
That means like lighter sentences, more focus on rehabilitation.
Those aren't bad things. What's bad is hey, this guy's clearly
shown a propensity for being a total skitso. Maybe he needs different
kinds of care and then and then you just let him go on the street.
It's a little different. Oh, right. We could do the Casey stuff
at some point as well. I I forgot that the Casey stuff's all
out there. We could cover all the Casey >> If you don't
have rules to enforce those nice things, you know what I mean?
It's always such a breath of fresh air when I go back to visit
my family in the suburbs of Long Island and I go to the CVS and
the toothpaste is free from their plexiglass prisons. I shouldn't
have to wait 10 minutes for some poor wage to come unlock the
ki so I can buy shampoo. We don't have to live that way. Maybe
he'll do great. Or maybe he gets into power and immediately to
the establishment like some other people.
I don't like to talk about it. I just don't know how the hell
anyone thought Andrew Cuomo was going to win. He killed a bunch
of grandmas during co >> as you admitted this week. You
personally altered the state health department report to underount
the death total to hide the death total and then evaded and lied
to these families for 5 years. So >> you [__]
ton of people [laughter] for what? Plus he doesn't even live
in New York City. He doesn't live in the city he's running to
be mayor of. Cuomo just kind of expected to win based on name
recognition alone and being like >> I'm sorry. I just find
that I find that kind of funny. Sorry. [laughter] He's just like
laughing. What the Oh, did you granny's? What the? Apparently,
the thing I suggested was what Andrew Cuomo did. He locked down
the old people somewhere else. Although, I don't understand how
Oh, whatever. It's fine. >> Hey, at least I'm not the other
guy.
Sound familiar? Trump actually offered a vision. Make America
great again. Mandani offered a vision. a New York City you can
afford. So people took a chance on him. People wanted something
different. Andrew Cuomo, he had no vision or anything. Oh man,
I love tuning into a debate about New York City and 80% of it
is about another country. >> The first foreign visit by
a mayor of New York is always considered significant. Where would
you >> No, Andrew. No, don't say the don't say the answer,
Andrew. >> First visit. I would visit the Holy >> I
would go to Israel. >> I'd make my >> Andrew, you're
Italian. Why wouldn't you go to Italy? THAT'S YOUR THAT'S WHERE
THE Vatican is. Aren't you Catholic? He's Italian. He's got to
be Catholic, >> My fourth trip to Israel. Mr. Mom >> I
would stay in New York City. My plans are to address New Yorkers
across the >> Dude, this dude, this is like the election
in this is American politics in a nutshell right now. Like, uh,
what's the best country on earth? Israel. Israel. Israel. Uh,
I think probably America. That's why I'm running as an American
politician. Oh, you win in a landslide. Amazing. Amazing how
that works. No way. Bro isn't focused on >> Mr. Mommy,
can I just jump in? Would you visit Israel? >> That was
the exact moment I knew Zoron was going to win. Bro was just
surrounded by NPCs. I love how they're like, "Where would you
go?" And Zoron was like, "I'm going to stay here." And instead
of being like, "No, Zoron." The question was, "Where would you
go?" They're like, "Why wouldn't you go to Israel?" Like, that's
the answer to the question. Like, that's just the default answer
to that question. His win was very much in part a direct response
to the affordability crisis that many Americans are facing. So,
what is the GOP's answer to the affordability crisis? Oh, great
news, guys. There is no affordability crisis. It doesn't exist.
It's all in your head, silly. Need to save money? Simply don't
buy your grandmother a Christmas present this year. >> Budget,
budget, budget. You need a plan. Also, remember, adults don't
need gifts, okay? Focus on the people in your life who are age
3 to 18. Grandma doesn't need slippers. If they don't live by
you, don't get them a gift. Now is not the time to spend and
break the bank. Zoran's win was also basically a
>> direct response to the housing crisis in America. So,
what is the GOP's response to the pie in the sky commi gobbledegook
that Zoron Mandani is selling? Surely they have a better solution.
>> Here we The White House is floating this idea. Bill
Py is saying, "Thanks to President Trump. We can indeed work
on the 50-year mortgage. A complete game >> God, the 50-year
mortgage. >> How does that work in dollars? Here you >> She
voted for Trump. I have no I have no idea who Shuan had voted
for. I doubt it matters right here. >> 30-year fixed mortgage.
Right now, you're paying $2,38 a month principal and interest
on a $400,000 home. At the bottom, under 50 years, you'd save
a couple hundred bucks a month. $1,822
>> Dude, they show this. Why don't they show the real number?
Here's the number I care about.
When the bank buy when the bank finances this mortgage for me,
how much do they make on each of these plans? That's like the
number one. When I go to when I go to get like a loan on something,
that's what I want to look at. Okay? Show me how much the bank
makes. I want to pick the one that's worse for you. Okay? That's
you making less money off of me. Whichever option is worse for
you, [__] you. Don't show me Don't show me this.
Okay. Oh, you you get a way lower monthly payment. No. Show me
why you're giving me a lower monthly payment. Show me the overall
How much more are you charging me? >> Interest that is
proposed. Do you like this idea? >> I do not like this
idea. >> Not lowering prices, not building more housing.
No, just being a good little slave to the bank for 50 years.
You might as well be a renaway forever in this case. Like, at
least you don't have to fix your own dishwasher. You will own
nothing and be happy. Doesn't that sound great, Jenz? Vote for
us. We'll release the Epstein files and finally drain the swamp.
Awesome. Finally, justice. Here comes the Epstein Files phase
1. We got all your favorite e celebs here. Uh, don't you think
that's a little tacky? I mean, like, this is an international
child trap. The Epstein files are on my desk. Oh, that's great.
That's great. That's That's what we've been waiting for. Well,
oh, they don't exist. Wait, what? Yeah, the Epstein files don't
exist. They're Democrat hoax. But you just said, "Hey, what the
That's my wallet." Sorry. Israel needs new weapons. Bye. What
do you want?
>> That just makes me
makes me think I need to go grab a video real quick. Hold on.
Give me a second. Why? What do you have to offer? >> Hey,
that's my wallet again. What are you people doing? Sorry. Israel
needs new weapons. Bye. The Epstein files are a really big deal.
This is not a partisan issue. You >> Bro, I I'm sorry.
I just
And if if as if I were going to make it better, I'm actually
going to make it worse. I'm going to make it worse.
This just reminded me of this clip. >> Okay. All right.
All right. You can have your border wall. Just vote for us one
more time and then we'll build. I
And then they get in and then they go,
boy. You voted for the wall. How about gay marriage?"
[laughter] >> I don't know that just that it it's like
exactly it's coded the exact same way. Okay. You voted for the
wall. How about gay marriage? >> You should absolutely
care about an international child trafficking a blackmail operation
consisting of the most powerful people in the world. And anyone
telling you to move on is coping, gaslighting, or in on it. If
whatever is in there is so damning that it is a national security
risk, the people deserve to know. Like I don't know about you,
but if we are paying taxes to a bunch of satanic pediles, uh
I would like to know that that is information I would like to
know. Like I already know I already know we're doing that, but
I would like some confirmation. Okay, so literally as I am filming
this, Trump is saying he is releasing the Epstein files. So I
guess they weren't a hoax. I'm going to be so honest. I have
no idea what the [__] is going on, you guys. I'm
sure when this video gets posted, there's already going to be
more things that have happened. Also, Mike Johnson apparently
said they need to make changes to the files to make sure we quote
don't do permanent damage to the political system. If releasing
the Epstein files would do damage to the political system,
I like it should do permanent damage to every Republican who's
ever like run on or or commented on the Epste thing, right? Like
like the fact that you need to edit it, every single one of them
ran on full transparency. We need to release everything. We can't
hold anything back. And now
they all lied. It was just all
>> Then so be it. Then it deserves to be damaged. It deserves
to be destroyed. Just release the files. After all, if you have
nothing to hide, you have nothing to fear. Isn't that right,
government? But it wasn't just the Epstein files thing that has
MAGA feeling a little demoralized lately. >> Does that
mean the H-1B visa thing will not be a big priority?
>> Oh, I'm saying I don't care if it does damage. I'm I'm
like not even talking about what's in the files only. I'm saying
right now a ton of Republicans, including JD Vance, should have
their careers destroyed
just from what's already happened.
Not even not even not even going off of what's in the files at
all. >> Don't care what's in the files. Care about how
they're acting, how they ran on it.
>> Trump is relicing the Epstein files.
>> Is
Thank you, Reuben Rubin. Thank you. I appreciate it, Reuben Rubin.
Thank you very much. Appreciate >> your administration.
If you want to raise wages for American workers, you can't flood
the country with with tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands
of foreign workers. >> You also do have to bring in talent
when you don't have >> talented. No, you don't. No, you
don't. We don't have talented people. >> No, you don't
have you don't have certain talents and you have to people have
to learn. >> We've talked about this a few times on this
channel. Actually, very recently in the male loser epidemic video,
the no talented Americans thing. >> That was uh that was
for the brief moment where Trump was totally for some reason
just totally
vacc. Okay. He was just like, "Oh yeah, this Vette guy, he knows
what we're doing. He knows what's up. Yeah, this VCT guy, he
knows. He's he's smart."
Trump got off that trade myth pushed on us by corpos and billionaires.
So they can hire foreign workers who will work for less money
and won't unionize. Worker drones who will work under the coercion
of deportation, essentially creating infinite scab labor. Even
though there are so many Americans in these fields looking for
jobs, but those spoiled Americans will ask for a living wage
so they can live in a 600t square apartment. How dare they? We
can't do that. So import 1 billion immigrants after all it's
good for business >> folks um are not thrilled about this
idea of hundreds of thousands of foreign
>> is there any talent not in the US like anything we are
short on um yeah I think there's I think basically always everywhere
in the world bar trained medical professionals are welcome like
in Canada I think in Canada it's basically like if Canada doesn't
have a policy around this already they should it's like if you're
if you're a doctor from anywhere you're welcome okay you can
have you can have a temporary residence on the way to American
or permanent residence like tomorrow.
So doctors from everywhere. Yeah, everywhere like everywhere
wants them. Um
what else is there? I think tech workers still there's like a
reasonable push but I don't know. I think that's going to cut
down really badly. Teachers are always needed. Yeah, but you
can't you have to train teachers where you are, right? You can't
bring that's one thing you can't import from other places. actually
didn't think about it, but teachers actually have a job security.
Like maybe the most secure jobs in the world cuz teachers are
always needed, but somehow they're always needed. They're always
in demand. You can't train them anywhere else. And they make
no money. How I don't understand how all of those things are
true.
It's literally just because
uh basically the only people who want to teach are people who
have a passion for it and they're going to teach no matter what.
So that's actually not true.
If we were to cut that in half, which perhaps makes some people
happy, you would have half the colleges in the United States
go out of business. >> And it's not that >> Oh, hold
on. I'm not talking about university. I'm talking about uh like
regular teachers,
um K to2 teachers. >> I want them, but I view it as a >> Unfortunately,
America does feel like nothing but three corporations in a trench
coat. But America is not a business. America is not a corporation.
It is a nation. The contrast of what Trump is saying here compared
to how he used to talk is staggering. Republicans embracing populism,
at least rhetorically, is what gave rise to Donald Trump and
fundamentally changed the way Republicans do politics in America.
If you go back and watch the debates of Donald Trump in 2016,
it's >> We should have never been in Iraq. We have destabilized
the Middle East. They lied. They said there were weapons of mass
destruction. There were none. And they knew there were none.
There were no weapons of mass. [laughter] All right. >> I
remember being like, damn, that's not how politicians in general
really talked at that time. Like we would see it from Bernie
Sanders and maybe like Ron Paul, but to get up on stage in a
Republican
>> Yeah. I wonder if that anything had anything to do with
the fact that he was not a politician.
Maybe you think >> of Republican donors saying that kind
of was unheard of. Bro is getting booed. Trump won in 2016 by
decrying the bloodlust and wararmongering of the Republican party,
but also by speaking to the economic woes of the average working-class
American. Basically saying, "I see you." to people who felt like
they haven't been seen by either party in a very long time. Like
I saw people in my life, my neighbors and stuff that we're all
like Obama voters like just flipped to Trump and now like all
of Long Island. Long Island is like the Florida of the Northeast,
bro. It is like Trump country there now. Before Trump
Oh, my nuggies are here. My nuggies are here. One second. One
second. I must go get my nuggies. It's nugie time.
To the affordability all the right
>> freaks like Lindsy Graham. So, I just want to say I
feel good about the Republican party. I feel good about where
we're going. >> God, this Lindsay this Lindsey Graham clip
is the most tonedeaf thing I've ever seen in my entire life.
How does this guy keep getting elected?
This is the This is the wor This is like optically maybe the
worst clip timing wise, optically. It's so bad. Everybody's like,
"Hey, I don't think we should uh support Israel anymore." He's
like, "We're killing all the right people and we're lowering
your taxes."
Shut up, Lindsey Graham. as a nation. We're killing all the right
people and we're cutting your taxes. Trump is my favorite president.
We've run out of bombs. We didn't run out of bombs in World War
II. >> Republicans, is that what you want your party to
be? Lowering taxes and people. We tried that already. To many
Republicans, the solution to the affordability crisis, wreaking
havoc on Americans, is simply trusting the free market, working
hard, and if that doesn't work, they bust out all >> If
you're a young person and you can't afford to live here, then
maybe you should not live here. I mean, that is a real thing.
Okay, I know that we we've now grown up in >> Dude. DUDE,
NO WAY. I didn't watch this.
Oh, why? Oh, why did I skip Ben on
Dude, what?
Oh my god.
I would be so I would be just raging to hear this if I were like
a conservative American. Okay. I'm raging to hear it as like
somebody who isn't in your country.
That's That's nuts.
Ben's headwear is growing in size. People say this all the time.
I think it's just hard to tell when he when he does his normal
setup where his hair ends because of because of how he's sitting
directly facing the camera and where the the kipia or the I think
it's Kipia where it begins >> society that says that you
deserve to live where you grew up. But the reality is that the
history of America is almost literally the opposite of that.
>> Ah yes, the classic just move. Just move from economic
zone 67 to economic zone 69. I don't know, man. Maybe some people
actually like where they live. Maybe they want to make their
community better. This is like the libertarian version of just
deal with it when you talk to leftists about crime. Like no,
we shouldn't just deal with it. We
>> uh the best part about that,
it actually echoes perfectly
the doom of the Democratic party. Okay. Hey, why don't you guys
just learn to code? Same vibe, exact same coding, exact same
lack of touch with reality with the average
No, he's not. He's not even right. He's not right.
I do think it's like crazy if you grew up in in a place and it's
now gone beyond your like standard of living and you are able-bodied.
You're willing to work like 50 hours a week.
Like there's no way this guy comes along and is just like, "Oh,
you should you should move. You should get the [__]
out of there." No. Stop bringing people in. Stop
something has to change. Okay. Something has to change.
Stop shipping. I I don't know. I I man
there's a lot of things working against each other there. Stop
devaluing my labor is probably what you need to say, but there's
just no solid solution to that. I don't know how you solve it,
to be honest with you. >> Shouldn't just move. Maybe we
can make the cities in our country livable and safe. Maybe better
things are possible. Actually, my husband and I moved away from
our families because of his job. And it sucks. It sucks raising
kids without an extended family around. Say hi to grandma on
FaceTime. Not normal. Not natural. When I was growing up, it
was like aunts and uncles and cousins and grandparents were just
coming in and out of my house like bringing over food like, "Hey,
I got some mangi. I would be babysat by my cousins and my aunts."
And because we moved away, my kid won't have that. And I wouldn't
be surprised if that's one reason many young people are This
is actually probably a way better point that actually way undercuts
Ben's whole idea cuz Ben would argue that these family units
sticking together
um he would argue that that's really important, right?
And whoa, just move away. What? I No, no, no. I think this is
actually a really good argument.
I didn't think about this. This is a great >> off having
children. The complete lack of community. The lack of a village.
If you can't afford to live where your family lives, just move
to Gary, Indiana, where there's nobody around and no jobs and
no family and no friends. But hey, at least you can afford a
house there. That's not how life should work, Ben. Maybe take
a step back and try to understand. Am I doing bird hands too
much? You guys have made me so insecure about the bird hands
thing ever since this meme. Listen, I'm a woman, okay? We are
programmed to scold children. And when no children are around,
we scold people on the internet. Okay. [laughter] Anyway, Nick
Fuentes is a far-right commentator and a controversial figure
to say the least. But his main topic he covers is Israel, which
is an extremely hot topic that many other right-wing commentators
seem to not want to touch. And the rare times they do touch it.
It's them telling you not to talk about it, questioning why you
care so much or shapeshifting into the woke mob they fought against
for so many years, calling you names, calling for you to be censored.
What's funny is they didn't care about any of Nick Wentis' rants
on like race or women. They only started caring when his rants
on Israel were blowing up. Nick recently
>> That's not true. That's I'm sorry. That's just not true.
Lots of people cared about Nick when he was ranting about black
people, too. In fact, unfortunately, the funny thing about black
people is somehow black people are like way way way
more confident
in like racism against them. Like black people are very immunized
against racism to be honest. So actually when Nick would rant
about black people for quite a while I I swear like the Carier
family and a bunch of other black people would react to his stuff
and blow it up further. They're like this is so funny. Look at
this racist little goober. LOOK AT THIS racist little goober.
Look at him. He's so cute. He's so racist.
It's like what? Wait. Shouldn't you guys be mad?
Um no. Black people. Black people don't care about Black people
care about going to like the bank and not getting a loan for
being black. I don't think black people really care that there
are white supremacists on the internet who who hate them. I don't
think that's like a
It's not up on the list of priorities. I don't think for black
people, right? Oh, so sure. DJ Denkey, I think there are like
lots of actual, you know, actual problems where racism can affect
black people's lives. I just think like the guy on the internet
who's putting clips out, I don't think people are like broadly
getting super mad about it. Unless I'm maybe I'm mistaken. Okay.
All right. Stop.
Crazy. We lost Kenny. Kenny's a groper now. Kenny just likes
good content. >> Did an interview with >> That's
not true. Kenny just likes edgy edgy beliefs and then good content
is like a second >> which completely ignited the MAGA civil
war that was brewing on the right for some time now. It got so
ridiculous that even Chuck Schumer went on the Senate floor and
called for a disavow of Nick
Well, what right-wing influencers attacked Nick for his racism
compared to the criticism? I mean all of the America first adjacent
people forever. Like they all pointed out like Sorry, did I say
America first? I meant all of the um I I was going to say Israel
first, but I mean um Turning Point the Turning Point USA people.
They all they all like hit him for his racism, too. It might
have been the Israel thing was like the most off-putting, but
if you remember back in the day, like like he wasn't just doing
like, oh, Israel shouldn't get money. He was doing like Holocaust
revisionism, Holocaust denial, like a very different thing, right?
I don't think he does it anywhere near as much now. In fact,
I think he's almost entirely dropped it,
but like it's now he's he's doing Israel skepticism overall and
doing a lot better, but he was like way more racist and people
used to hit him for the racism stuff as well, right? If you remember
when he went on that panel with Sneo and like on Destiny stream
with Sneo and Abba and Jitton,
that was what blew that panel up was when when Destiny kind of
lied and said that he said black dudes was like dogs for white
women, right? Not quite what Fentes said. A little different.
And Young Dawn. Yeah, >> sir. With all due respect, none.
Why do politicians need a resolution in the Senate to disagree
with a citizen? Hello. I have gathered you all here today to
disavow [__] 420.
>> Okay, hold on. Sorry. We I should back this up a little
bit so I don't miss her point. How long ago was he saying we
need to clean up his image? So that is a different point Dingling
is which is a
so I think he approaches this point from a place where like he's
he's approaching it from a racist point but there is something
to the idea that you say you want to dethize the Holocaust in
that it is a lot of people treat the Holocaust as if it's a very
unique genocide. It is something that like
it's just totally different from anything else that's happened
in human history. And that's probably not true, right? like the
the
the hello tomorrow is a little different quite a bit different
but the great leap forward way more death right and and other
people had the same sorts of intents
but
I I think when he talks about dethizing the Holocaust it's about
not letting it be used as a weapon to defend Israel is basically
the idea okay now I I think he tries to get away and this is
not me like I can fully admit he was a Holocaust denier right
he is he probably sorry he's he is a Holocaust denier. I'm just
saying strategically I don't think he's doing that a lot in terms
of his content now. It's just it's not a good look and I think
he's realized that now that he's unbanned from platforms he can
just actually do real content. He doesn't have to do that. though
I don't know seem seems to be the case >> seem to not want
to touch and the rare times they do touch it it's them telling
you not to talk about it questioning why you care so much or
shapeshifting into the woke mob they fought against for so many
years calling you names calling for you to be censored what's
funny is they didn't care about any of Nick Fentis' rants on
like race or women they only started caring when his rants on
Israel were blowing up Nick recently did an interview with Tucker
Carlson which completely ignited the MAGA civil war that was
brewing on the right for some time now it got so ridiculous that
even Chuck Schumer went on the Senate floor and called for a
disavowel of Nick Fuentes. Sir, with all due respect, none. Why
do politicians need a resolution in the Senate to disagree with
a citizen? Hello. I have gathered you all here today to disavow.
>> It's uh it's literally just it's political maneuvering
obviously.
>> People can't afford groceries. Charles Ben Shapiro in
particular has spent >> I I'll say
it's sort of it's sort of funny how that is like the number one
way to signal out of belief like this is what we pointed out
when when Chuck Schumer originally did that. It's like just watch
for the guy for the people who come out and just go uh Chuck
there's an affordability crisis Chuck there's other stuff there's
other stuff going on right now. If that's like their only comment
on that
it probably it's like a little red flag. You should watch. You
should just watch and and understand it, right? But I think he
just wanted ba he wanted Republicans to be on board with disavowing
the guy. I actually don't even know. Did they did they vote to
disavow? What even happened with that vote? Nobody says what
happened with the vote. Was it just like uniform disavow or something?
The last few months extremely confused and angry about Zoran
Mani and Nick Quenta becoming popular in the mainstream all while
his numbers continue to drop. I honestly don't think he understands
what is happening here. So, I am going to explain to you, Ben,
what exactly is going on here. The American dream does not exist
anymore for most people. Young people followed advice that worked
for older generations, and it got them nowhere. Young people
are tired of this stale, moldy, old, dead consensus that has
dominated American politics for a very long time. The one that
dragged us into all these foreign wars and sold us out for some
cheap plastic [__] from China. Young people are tired
of being told to sit down and shut up and pledge allegiance to
the free market in a country that seems to not give a [__]
about them, as well as a foreign country they have absolutely
no connection to. For so long, establishment hacks and establishment
shills looked at the issues bothering the people and just kind
of dismissed them. Can't afford to live where you grew up? Just
move. Don't like that the toothpaste is locked behind plexiglass?
Just deal with it. I think it's kind of [__] up how
you work 40 hours a week and still can't afford to pay rent.
What are you, some kind of communist? You don't like funding
a genocide with your tax dollars? What are you, anti-semitic?
If you don't address the issues of the people, the people will
gravitate towards those who are addressing those issues. It's
>> This is This is
actually like fine political analysis or whatever. It's It's
obvious, but it's like usually I watch you and I'm like, "You're
kind of dumb." But this is just true, right? This No, this is
absolutely a thing you can do. So, here's here's the problem
with a lot of people. Okay, you guys are saying cringe. Here's
the problem with how a lot of liberals try to argue on the internet.
Um um actually economically like GOP is not really stagnating
and there wasn't a recession and there's no there's like this
is a vibe session actually and everybody's like, "Hey, I feel
like I can't pay for anything." And it's like, okay, you you
can keep you can keep saying over and over again how oh actually
like GOP wise we're doing sorry GOP GDP wise we're doing really
good. You can keep saying that over and over again but realistically
people are feeling pressed. They're feeling like stretched for
their dollar. They feel like they can't work and just make a
living wage anymore. That's like a feeling that's going around
and you can say oh well it's just rael rousing or whatever. But
you have to engage with it. You have to you have to deal with
that feeling. You don't deal with the feeling at all. If you
just tell them they're crazy, eventually they're just going to
stop caring about what you say. Eventually, they'll go to somebody
who's just going to lie to them.
GOP wise, we're doing really bad. Yeah, GOP wise country is not.
>> It's not Mandani's fault he won. It's yours. It's not
Nick Fentes's fault he's popular. It's yours. The tragedy of
Ben Shapiro is that he led a life worshiping the free market
only to lose in the free marketplace of ideas. Now, with all
this neocon rhetoric coming out of the GOP, are the Democrats
going to pick up the populist ball that they are fumbling? Are
they actually going to get their [__] together? Well,
they are trying because they have written an article called Deciding
to Win, where after interviewing over 300,000 American voters
from both parties, they may have finally discovered the secret
to winning. To give ourselves the best chance to win, we recommend
the following changes to our approach. Democrats need to one,
focus our messaging on an economic program centered on lowering
costs, growing the economy, creating jobs, and expanding the
social safety net. Two, advocate for popular economic policies.
moderate our positions where our agenda is unpopular, including
on issues like immigration, public safety, energy production,
and some identity and cultural issues. So, basically, it took
you guys 10 years, millions of dollars, and dozens of Microsoft
team meetings to come to the conclusion that everyone has been
saying forever. You wasted a decade worshiping at the altar of
mentally ill Karens, and now you're acting like, "Hey,
she didn't skip three." But, I mean, she's obviously just going
to stick to the things that prove her point. I don't know what
three would have been. I don't know. This is all This is all
like I get it. She's trying to take a victory lap cuz she's been
saying go populist, go populist, go populist for a long time
and nobody wants to go populist. Right? This is the Bernie versus,
you know, it's the Bernie Bros trying to get their pound of flesh
because they feel like they've been correct about, hey, Bernie's
the answer. Hey, Bernie's the answer. Hey, Bernie's the answer.
And for a long time, people like, people don't like Bernie. People
don't like Bernie. People don't like Bernie. But it's like, no,
probably something akin to what Bernie was proposing was the
answer. And you guys just didn't want to hear it. I don't know.
It probably >> What if we were normal? is a groundbreaking
political discovery.
You I could have told you all this for free. It is a bad sign
that it took you over a decade to come to the same conclusion
that my audience has come to like a decade ago and they're all
Please reflect on this. I beg of you. Also, what do you mean
you had unpopular positions on public safety? Like, why would
you even say that out loud? Yeah, let's vote for the party that
admits it was wrong about the issue of crackheads shanking people
in the street. I love
>> again. I ah it's just
this is why you should just lie. Unfortunately for politicians,
they should just lie. You never say you're lying. They should
just lie about everything all the time. People literally can't
handle actual information. [__] >> Quote from
Nancy Pelosi randomly shoved in here. Winning an election is
a decision. You make a decision to win and then you make every
decision in favor of winning. How deep. How thoughtprovoking.
Thank you Nancy. What? >> I She shouldn't like that. That's
Nancy Pelosi just said what I said, but in a way more tactful
way. First, you decide whether or not you want to win, and they
make every decision in favor of winning. That's her just saying,
"I want to lie. We need to lie to these people. They're too stupid."
Why did she just cheer for that? Why did she just cheer for that?
That's her saying, "We need to politic harder. We need to lie
to you people cuz you're too dumb." >> What would we do
without you? Probably win an election. Democrats have changed
our focus. In comparison with the Democratic Party of 2012, today's
Democrat party is more focused on issues like climate [clears throat]
change, democracy, abortion, and identity and cultural concerns
and less focused on the economy and middle class. The table below
shows the shift through an analysis of the prevalence of selected
words in the 2024 Democratic Party platform in comparison with
the 2012 Democratic Party platform. This whole study is really
interesting, but I need you guys to see this chart because when
I first saw this, the scream I scrept. So, Democrats since 2012
have increased their rhetoric on race by sit down
On the gays, 1,044%.
Their rhetoric on men has decreased by 51%. It is now negative
51%. On fathers, negative 100%. They just stop talking about
that. Veterans 31. The economy negative 51 because nobody cares
about that, right? the middle
>> I so the thing that you need to make this meaningful
this is this is unfortunately like not meaningful in a vacuum
right what you need is the same study to take place on Republicans
and then see the changes and then look at the delta to see oh
Republicans have made gains culturally in the past while what
are like the deltas I don't think I don't think there's a difference
in rhetoric on the gays because I think Republicans have been
driving that conversation for a while on the gays specifically
trans people Like I don't think Republicans are talking less
about it. They're talking way more about it. >> Middle
class 79% but I guess you can't really talk about something that
is disappearing and jobs 47%. It somehow gets worse. Apparently
voters trust Republicans more on the most important issues to
them and trust Democrats the most on the least important issues
to them. Like they literally care the least about LGBT but trust
Democrats the most with it. The most popular Democratic policies
among voters are things like lowering drug prices, banning stock
trading, expanding Medicare, and raising the minimum wage. While
the most >> It's so funny how when the economy was going
gang busters, when when all this money was being borrowed and
and the the stock market was like hitting setting new records
every single day, everyone had these priorities that didn't really
matter like the DEI stuff was blowing up. There's all cultural
issues, right? And it's like, oh, you you get the wrong idea
of what matters. people start focusing on things that that literally
don't matter at all. It's very interesting. But then when when
the what is it? When act meets grass. Okay, looking for the right
idiom. When where when act meets grass, when it all comes down
to it, it's the economy. >> Unpopular Democratic policies
are things like abolishing the police, providing free healthcare
to illegal immigrants, and affirmative action. You're telling
me this for the first time? But Democrats, here is some advice
for free. You can't just be MAGA light. Why would people drink
Mr. Pib when Dr. Peppers right there. You know what I'm saying?
You got to bring something different, something better to the
table. And that difference should be working class focused economic
populism. I don't just want two neocon parties. Okay. But all
this is pointless when it's clear the Dems are not changing at
all. They're just going to change their messaging. They're putting
pretty
things were gang busters post 2020. No.
No. But they've changed their messaging entirely. Or or at least
like that stuff's basically gone away since 2020. It's just like
it takes obviously things lag, but I'm telling you that like
nobody cared after 2020. Nobody gave a wrapping paper and a bow
on a big fat smelly turd. There's a chance that the Democrats
may win based entirely on orange man bad again, which means they
might get into office by learning absolutely nothing again. Then
the voters will go, "Oh my god, nothing has changed." And then
they'll vote for a Republican. American politics is just a revolving
door of villains, isn't it? Rest assured, whoever wins, we lose.
If you're actually going to do this, if you're actually going
to do what you're saying in this little article, you better be
going whole hog, not just a tip. I'm talking embracing shelism.
>> Okay, you >> for many years, I have been smeared
as many things. Grifter, flipflopper, fence sitter, racist, homophobic,
but I'm not a grifter, flipflopper, or a fence sitter. I'm simply
living in 2015. You see, America has been a hyper capitalist,
economically center right, socially center-left country since
about the midentury. And I know libertarians in my audience are
going to be like, "It's not capitalism, it's cronyism." Okay,
whatever the you want to call it, it sucks. Okay, so what if
instead, and hear me out, what if instead we were a more people
focused, community focused, workingass focused, economically
left, socially right country. All the data shows more people
fall into that.
Every listen, somehow everybody's
adopting what I call a third position. Okay, there's like left
and right and then there's this third position. Don't Google
it, but there's like this third position, which is like socially
conservative,
okay? Economically
liberal, economically left. All right. It's it's some it's like
I'm I'm thinking like the third position is what you could call
it. You could run as like a third position candidate. I I'm just
>> quadrant. The populist quadrant, the shulilist quadrant,
if you will, then the current system we are in today. If a shulless
party existed, it would be incredibly popular. But it doesn't
exist. And that's probably by design. Honestly, the social democrat
party of Denmark has passed many progressive policies that liberals
in America would only dream of. Protection from rent hikes, free
college and healthcare, carbon taxes, and a very strong welfare
system. But the social democrat party also believes in a strict
immigration policy. They believe that if immigration is too fast
or chaotic, it puts pressure on working-class communities, weakens
social unity, and makes it harder to maintain their strong welfare
system. >> So, they have common sense. >> Grifter
Denmark is I feel like so many people nowadays are like terminally
left right to the point where like they look at issues and instead
of being like that solution makes sense to me. I I believe that,
I agree with that. They instead go that's the leftwing solution.
Therefore, I will believe in that. And it's so stupid and hyperartisan.
It makes absolutely no sense to me. And that's why I think like
a lot of left right hyperartisan people don't understand me or
people like me. That's why they call me a centrist or fence sitter
or flip-flopper or whatever. And it's like >> Denmark is
way smaller than the US. Also Denmark it's a different culture.
Like the US can't handle not being number one. The US always
wants to fight to be number one, right? That's like and Americans
have that in their like DNA. We have to be number one. Denmark's
like we're cool. We're just chilling, right? We're just chilling.
We're cool over here. We're having a great time over here. We're
we're good. we we got what we got and we're we're good with it.
That's like that's the Denmark attitude. That's all of the what
do you call it? All the Nordic countries are just like that,
right? They're just like they actually have a culture where it's
like it's kind of weird to make a big spectacle in public. It's
kind of weird to put yourself above others. It's weird to do
all of these things. And because it's weird, they have like a
they'll let their government do different stuff. But in America,
it's like, "No, I'm the most important person." Everybody >> like,
"No, I'm not a fence sitter. I have many strong opinions. you
you just don't like them. And no, I'm not a flip-flopper. Just
because you don't understand the concept of having opinions that
don't perfectly fall on the arbitrary, always changing left right
axis that is American circus politics. There's nothing incoherent
about my beliefs on paper. None of them contradict one another.
I don't understand. She likes free healthcare but doesn't want
to chemically creat. She believes in workers rights but wants
a stricter border. I I don't get it. Like where is the contradiction?
I'm basically just Bernie Sanders before he got his spine surgically
removed by the DNC. In conclusion, MAGA and the Republican party
embracing populism is what made them so popular in the first
place. But if the Republican party's answer to all these issues
young people are having, >> I I wonder what she thinks
of the like, okay, sure, the MAGA party's embrace of populism
is why they're popular
now. What populist policies have they actually passed? How how
what populist policies what part of like economic populism have
they followed through on? I I'm just curious.
I I would love to know what her answer to that would be >> is
you just move. You're not talented. Maybe you'll own a home when
you're 70 years old. >> Like I understand what people want
to hear, but close the border. Is the border closed right now?
If we look at the end of like the first Trump term, are we going
to see like massive massive crash of uh of border crossings?
>> They're doomed. Like they had a small
>> I guess on immigration, right? Crackdowns sending ice
to cities and stuff. I guess maybe tough on crime, but that's
not really popular. >> With populism and ghosted it. >> Tariffs
is not populism. I'm sorry. >> And dump like a fat they're
ashamed of and won't bring out on dates in public. As I'm editing
this, Trump and Mdani had a meeting together and it was very
>> We were discussing when Bernie Sanders was out of the
race, I picked up a lot of his votes and people had no idea.
When he was uh put out of the race, I think quite unfairly if
you want to know the truth. Uh many of the Bernie Sanders voters
voted for me and I felt very comfortable, frankly, in seeing
that and saying that. I would feel
The bulcanization of immigration policy is one of the worst things
to happen to North America. What the does that even mean? I know
what bulcanization is, but I What do you mean on immigration
>> Very, very comfortable being in New York, and I think
much more so after the meeting. We agree on a lot more than I
would have thought. >> I'm sorry. This is my new favorite
problematic Yahi ship. They love each other. Maybe it's not over,
folks. Maybe the power of friendship and populism will save us
all. Listen, I want my >> Hold on. I need the Trump face
again.
>> The [__] That's a That's a That's a crazy
screenshot. >> Maybe it's not over, folks. Maybe the power
of friendship and populism will save us all. Listen, I want my
kids to grow up in a safe and affordable world where they can
get jobs and they can >> Canadian caller, answer that question.
I'm going to finish the video and then we can
have the same for their kids. And I feel like at the end of the
day, that's what most people want left and right. They just have
different ideas on how to get there. It just so happens my ideas
happen to be the correct ones. And if you disagree with them,
you will be sent to the re-education camp. Do you want one? Do
you want a nugie? Pledge your allegiance. >> I don't. Dude,
it's so gay when they do that bit. Gross.